Joe: From exclusive
items to portion sizes,
we wanted to find all the differences
between KFC in the US and Italy.
This is "Food Wars."
New season, Italy. New host.
I want to introduce you to a familiar
Food Insider face: Claudia.
Let's start with the
Original Recipe chicken.
If you're buying just
the original chicken,
you can get a two-piece. One is huge.
We also have lots of bucket options,
but most of them combine
the Original Recipe,
wings, and tenders.
If you only want the original chicken,
the largest size we have
is a six-piece bucket.
Looks a bit scary.
The other bucket options
include a variety of chicken,
such as tenders and hot wings.
For example, if you
want to feed two people,
you can get the 10-piece bucket.
This contains four tenders
and six crispy tenders.
And if you want to feed four people,
you can get this big boy here.
This one is a 16-piece bucket
and contains four Original Recipe,
four tenders, four crispy
tenders, and four wings.
This is actually the
biggest thing on the menu.
Then in the US, KFC's chicken
comes in four portion sizes.
You can start off by getting
a one-piece à la carte,
then a two-piece with a combo,
a three-piece with a combo,
and a four-piece with a combo,
all of which come with
a side of your choice,
a biscuit, and a drink.
Then for the buckets,
we have an eight-piece,
the 12-piece,
and last but not least,
this luscious bucket,
16 pieces of chicken.
Dinner is served in America.
You can get those in
either original or crispy.
That makes our biggest bucket
166% bigger than Italy's.
I've actually never really had KFC before.
Chicken is not so popular in Italy,
especially fried chicken served like that.
So I'm really curious to try it and see.
Yeah, nice.
Not a lot of spices. It's
just, like, fried chicken,
which is what we were promised.
Let's see how one chicken drumstick weighs
compared to Italy.
Claudia: 64 grams.
Joe: 97 grams.
Is anyone surprised that the
chicken in the United States
is bigger than every other country
we've done this "Food Wars" with?
In Italy, we also have hot wings,
and they come in a five-piece
and in a 18-piece bucket.
This one is designed for three people.
18 wings in the US is definitely
for one person, not three.
I could have six wings
and then have a full meal.
So, they're advertised as hot wings.
I think to an Italian palate,
yeah, you could say these are spicy.
We also got wings here in the US.
Now, currently, at least the
KFC I went to here in Burbank
has one size of wings, the eight-piece.
Go ahead and take the bones out.
Crispy.
Heat I can notice that isn't overwhelming.
Perfectly fine.
Next are the fries.
In Italy, you can get three sizes:
a small, medium, and large.
In the US we got two sizes of fries:
the individual and the large.
Claudia: Let's weigh our biggest size.
[laughs] I never grow tired of that.
Is this the lowest we've gotten?
We've gone to the same KFC every time,
but apparently they
have fired that scooper
because he or she was being too generous.
In Italy, KFC offers drinks in two sizes:
a medium and a large.
Drinks in the US, you get
two fountain-drink sizes,
the regular and the large.
I will point out to you,
Claudia, and the rest of Italy,
that our regular, the smallest
drink you can get at a KFC,
is 591 milliliters,
which is much bigger than your large.
But if you really want
your thirst quenched,
you can get yourself the big boy. Guszh!
That is a half gallon, 64 fluid ounces,
or 1,892.7 milliliters
of beverage.
Claudia: Let's measure the
large one to see if that's true.
Joe: Supposed to be 887.
Let me just see if we can
get it up to 800. Whoa.
This is just 800.
The messes that this
show forces me to make.
If you are incredible at balancing
and you don't want a cap,
I guess this is OK
if you're just going to sit
at your table like [slurps].
Here's everything that you
can get at KFC in Italy
that you won't find in the US.
Here's everything you'll
find at a KFC in the US
you won't find in Italy.
We have one exclusive chicken
option you can't get in Italy.
That is the extra-crispy.
This is probably close to what you get,
the Original Recipe.
And then you got the extra-crispy.
I mean, obviously, it's night and day.
Volume up on this one.
This is regular [crunching],
and of course the extra-crispy
[louder crunching].
If you're wondering, yes, way better,
way more flavorful. Mm!
We don't have extra-crispy
chicken here in Italy,
but if you order tenders,
you're going to get original and crispy.
It does look much crispier.
It also looks, it just
looks much sadder as well,
because it's literally flopping.
At least I can see the chicken.
I can see some meat in there.
This one is completely
hidden in the batter.
Like, it could be anything.
Another exclusive are the KFC nuggets.
You can get these in
varieties of five, eight,
12, and 36.
I went with the five-piece.
Now, Claudia, take a good look at this.
You in Italy have popcorn chicken.
Besides potential size differences,
I really don't know what else
is different about these.
In Italy we don't have nuggets,
but we have popcorn chicken.
We got the large, but it comes
also in small and medium.
Quietly sometime last year,
KFC just took popcorn
chicken off the menu,
and I'm pretty bummed about that.
I mean, I like the nuggets,
but the popcorn chicken, man.
It's just something because
they're a lot smaller,
and then the chicken-to-skin ratio
is more in favor of the skin,
so you get a lot of that
savory skin in there.
RIP, popcorn chicken.
You're very lucky, Claudia.
You are very lucky.
Were you guys the guinea pigs for this,
or are we the guinea pigs for
a new recipe or something?
I think I prefer a whole piece.
I think bingeing on
little bits of chicken,
it's so un-Italian
that I'm not sure that I'll
be getting used to that.
Snacking on little bits of fried chicken
while in a convenient to-go box
while driving or walking around
is so American, and I love it.
I gotta try these.
This is what America's all about.
Let's move on to the chicken sandwiches.
In Italy, we have the Zinger.
This is supposed to be Italy's
version of the spicy chicken
that you guys have in the US.
I don't know, Joe, how does
that look like? Similar?
Yes, Claudia, your Zinger sandwich
looks a little bit like
our spicy chicken sandwich.
Here's ours, and we only
have pickles on ours,
so no lettuce and tomato.
But after I took a bite,
you can see there's, like, some red here,
so that's supposed to be the spice.
There's the tiniest, tiniest,
tiniest spice, to be honest.
Then, moving on, we have
this tiny little thing,
the Krunky.
Crunchy or Krunky.
This one here is on the value menu,
so it's a cheaper option.
And then we've got the Colonel,
named after Colonel Sanders.
We don't really have colonels here.
I think we do, but we
keep them for the army.
I don't think they've ever
opened a chicken restaurant.
Then we got the Double Colonel.
Does that mean that another person joined?
Then we have the Kentucky
chicken and bacon.
I have to say, this is the biggest bacon
that I've seen in
Italian fast-food chains.
This to me feels quite, quite fake.
You can also get this one in a double.
And then we have the chicken grilled.
So much sauce. Sad, sad
lettuce hanging off mayo.
You can also get the double crispy,
which is two chicken tenders in a bun.
Here are sandwiches you can get in the US
you can't get in Italy,
starting down here.
The classic Chicken Little.
I don't know, it's just a
tender in between two buns.
Here's what I would do: I would go to KFC,
I'd stand in line, I'd order
my meal and get one of these,
and then demand they give me this
while I wait for the rest of my food.
It's nothing. It's nothing.
It's like an appetizer.
And then, of course, just
the regular chicken sandwich.
I have said on record several times
that I think KFC might have the best
fast-food chicken sandwich in America.
There's also apparently an
ultimate barbecue fried chicken sandwich.
That was new. I think it came and went.
As an Italian, I'm not so
big on chicken burgers.
I think the idea of
having chicken in a burger
doesn't really resonate so well with us.
So it almost hurts my eyes.
There's just too much brown in it.
Like, I want to see more color.
Yeah, that's absolutely not the case here.
As you can see, our chicken is deep-fried
and covered in a mayo-y sauce.
We're eating chicken
all the time in America.
Yeah, we eat a lot of beef,
but we also eat a lot of chicken,
and it is in no way diet
food here. Not at all.
We also used to have twisted
wraps here at KFC in Italy,
but suddenly they're
not on the menu anymore.
They're still worth mentioning, though,
because of the hilarious
advertising campaign.
When KFC launched them in Italy,
they actually designed
Italian leather handbags
supposed to hold your Twisters,
which is a bit of a knockoff
to the Fendi Baguette bag.
All right, we might not have
Italian bags for our wraps,
but we do have KFC Crocs.
Look how cool those look.
[crickets]
We do have a couple wrap options.
You can only get them
through the KFC application,
which is not how I ordered.
Anyway, you can get the classic
one with a crispy tender.
There's also a spicy one
that I assume is spicier.
And, apparently, you can
get two of them for $5,
which is a pretty good
deal. But I didn't get that.
Here's a few hilarious things
you can't get in Italy.
Over here's the Famous Bowl.
Yes, Claudia, I know you're
dying to know all about this,
so I will tell you now.
It is nuggets, mashed
potatoes, gravy, corn,
cheese, all in one convenient tub.
So, this would be, I guess,
what's considered a bite.
It's really heavy.
It's gotta be 90% mashed potato.
It's a lot.
Another American exclusive
is this, a chicken pot pie.
Look at the size of this thing.
I think this would just
profoundly confuse every Italian.
Here's the thing about the
mashed potatoes and gravy.
You have to get them together.
Having them separately
seems very strange to me.
It is a classic US side dish,
especially with things like fried chicken.
Apparently when Colonel
Sanders sold the business,
he compared the mashed
potatoes in a Manhattan store
to "wallpaper paste" topped with "sludge."
But that was back in the '70s,
so hopefully they've
made some improvements.
I'd say that they have.
I mean, I know, like, those
mashed potatoes look so dry.
I understand you want to put
some sort of liquid on them.
I'd just not have any of it.
But for once,
the potatoes don't look
radioactively yellow,
so that should be a good sign.
We happen to have some Italian-style
sides here on the menu,
although I have no idea who
called this Italian style,
because none of these
really look Italian to me.
We have cheese puffs.
To me, these look like fried Babybels.
That's the only cheese that I can think of
that has this shape.
I think it's some kind of mozzarella.
Yeah, OK.
Yeah, we have bread.
Just, like funny bread.
It looks very dry, just by looking at it.
And then we have corn on the cob.
The US has off the cob.
This is not Italian.
I've never seen an Italian
person having corn on the cob.
In Italy, we also have four salads,
but we were not able to get them today.
Those are grilled chicken,
crispy chicken, and original chicken,
which, we don't know how that
differs from the crispy one,
and a veggie salad.
Right, Claudia, look at that.
Look at that mac and cheese.
It's American mac and cheese.
I mean, I don't really have
thoughts about mac and cheese,
because to me that's just not Italian.
We just sort of gave up on it and be like,
"You want it? It's yours."
Yeah, I get it. Like, bright yellow.
But Claudia, what you can't tell
is how good this tastes.
Other US sides you can get here: coleslaw.
Claudia was talking about corn on the cob.
We got corn off the cob, aka sweet corn.
I'm just thinking, in terms
of the American experience,
I don't want to be all,
like, doing this at my desk
when I get KFC for lunch, you know?
I just want to eat it and get going, so.
Another thing we have here, biscuits.
And I feel like you get these
with these types of meals
because it's good at sopping up things,
like good at sopping up the gravy.
On their own, they're
just so ... [thudding].
I want to see if I can eat
one without any liquid,
like, how long it takes me
to eat a dry one. Ready?
This is how dry these
are. Ready? Time me. Go.
Only halfway through!
Ugh, it hurts to talk.
Time.
Yeah, not my favorite.
Another exclusive you
can get here in the US
is a piece of à la carte chicken.
I feel like if you went into
a KFC in Italy and was like,
"I just want one drumstick,"
they'd give it to you.
I don't think they'd
really push back on it.
But our menu specifically has,
you get an individual piece of chicken.
You can get a drumstick,
a thigh, or a breast.
You get chicken in this hand,
Famous Bowl in this hand,
and walk right into traffic.
Sauce talk, let's go.
Discorso di la salsa.
In Italy, we have some exclusive sauces,
starting from the original.
I know you guys in the
US have the KFC sauce.
Does this look similar?
I think if I were making sauces,
I would've just continued,
you know, trialing others after this one.
Yeah, it's, like, a
mayo-y barbecue ketchup.
And then we have the smoky barbecue sauce.
And then we have the sweet imperial sauce.
That's a sweet and sour sauce.
Very lemony, but fresh.
Yeah, it's a nice one. I like this.
Then move on to the 2 hot 4 U.
Jelly-like.
It's not too hot for you,
it's just too bad for me.
Moving on, we also have garlic sauce.
I know you guys associate Italy
and Italian cuisine with garlic.
Please stop doing that.
We don't really like it.
Then we have a fresh pepper one.
This one apparently contains cheese.
Tastes like not much, to be honest.
We also have creamy curry.
Finally, we couldn't
get the only olive oil,
but we do have olive oil and white vinegar
and olive oil and balsamic vinegar.
I don't know if you want to
consider olive oil a sauce.
I have mixed feeling about it,
because that's definitely more dressing.
Are you curious to see how
chicken olive oil tastes like?
Let's try it.
Olive oil and balsamic vinegar. Let's see.
Kind of brought it back
to life a little bit,
because it had cooled down.
Yeah, I should do this
more often, actually.
It tastes less fried for some reason.
Because I always associate olive oil
with, like, grilled chicken.
So if you want to trick
your mind into thinking
that you're eating grilled
chicken and not fried,
maybe all you have to do is
pour some olive oil on it.
Joe: Honey mustard.
Honey barbecue.
That's good. Buffalo ranch.
If you are unaware, we have a sauce here
that usually is on wings
called the Buffalo sauce.
It's a vinegary hot sauce
that is a little north of mild.
And the reason that
Buffalo ranch is a thing
is because when you eat Buffalo
wings and they're spicy,
you dip the wings in ranch, a
second sauce, to cool it down.
So we as Americans are used
to pairing Buffalo sauce on the wings
with ranch dressing.
So they were like, let's
just put it in one,
because God forbid we have two sauces.
But if you want to have
just regular ranch,
everyone on the internet
come at me, all right?
Ranch is just OK. It all tastes the same.
Also we have a hot sauce.
A honey sauce.
We have a lot of dessert
options here in Italy.
Most of them are just ice cream.
We start from a plain ice cream cone.
Then you can get sundaes.
They come plain, caramel flavor,
Nutella, strawberry, and chocolate.
And then we have these, the Kream Balls.
They come with Nutella flavor, caramel,
strawberry, and chocolate.
They're kind of similar to a sundae,
but they have this crunchy bottom.
And apparently the caramel one
is supposed to have lots of layers.
This is the caramel one.
But I'm not sure we can
judge the number of layers,
because it has absolutely melted.
So, we got a Nutella Kream
Ball and a caramel one.
You know those backpacks for cats?
I think it's the same thing here.
I'm curious about the crunchy bottom.
Oh, yeah, that is crunchy.
Actually it reminds me a little bit of
the Algida, the Cornetto.
It may have another name in the US.
And they have that
crunchy bit at the bottom.
I mean, for us Italian, Nutella
is like the OG chocolate.
Before chocolate always comes Nutella,
just no questions asked.
It's always been like this.
And before cream as well.
The only exclusive dessert
option we have in America
is this: a chocolate cake.
And it just occurred to me,
I've actually never had this cake.
Let's see how we did.
Perfect.
Cooked beautifully.
It's got the right amount
of bounce, isn't dried out.
And now we taste it.
Exquisite.
You keep baking like that,
you can win this competition.
I started off as Gordon Ramsay.
Every impression I do of
anyone is just kind of that.
This is actually pretty good.
Yeah, they had those
balls, those Kream Balls,
which is kind of a weird thing to call it.
No, I don't want any of those.
I get it. I like dessert
just as much as the next guy.
But KFC, I want to load
up on fried chicken.
I want to load up on mac and cheese.
I want to load up on mashed potatoes.
I want to load up on corn.
If only someone could put
it all in one bowl for me.
Dessert? No, I want to eat fried chicken
until I'm about to burst,
and then I'm out. So.
The exclusive drinks in Italy are
7Up, Lipton iced tea, and beer.
Fountain drinks you can get in the US.
We do have a bunch of exclusives.
I didn't get every single one, relax.
All right, starting down here.
Sweet tea.
Oh, yeah, their lemonade.
It's really good. It's addictive.
And our lemonade is not
carbonated, it's still.
Mountain Dew, it's fantastic.
And the reason I saved this one for last,
it's something you can get
exclusively at the KFC in the US,
it's Mountain Dew Sweet Lightning.
It's so good. Like, you
just know it's super sweet,
and super chemically, but I love it.
Other drinks you can get at
a US KFC that we did not get
was Starry and blackberry lemonade,
which is currently unavailable.
Which country's getting
a better deal on its KFC?
Let's compare a few
menu items to find out.
Looking at the chicken
sandwich combo meal,
which comes with a side
and a medium drink,
this whole thing in Los
Angeles would cost you $10.99.
Note, if you got each item
individually, added up,
it would be $12.77.
In Italy, you can also get a similar meal
that is called a Zinger meal,
and that includes a sandwich,
a side of choice, and a drink.
This will cost you 10 euros and 40 cents.
At the time of recording,
that is equal to $11.52.
So that is 5% more
expensive than the US meal.
If you order these items individually,
that will cost you 13 euros and 60 cents,
and that's about $15.06.
We also took a look at
KFC's most expensive items.
In Italy, the most
expensive item on the menu
is the 16-piece bucket.
This one costs 42 euros 90 cents,
which is about $47.51.
This is supposed to feed four people
for $11.87 per person.
The most expensive item on the US menu
is the 16-piece chicken meal,
which includes 16 pieces of chicken,
original or crispy,
four large sides, eight biscuits,
and it costs you $52.99.
Now, this is meant to feed
seven to eight people.
Sure.
And it costs roughly $6.62 per person,
which is 44% cheaper than
Italy's per-person cost.
Italy KFC puts a lot of effort
into its meals and special offers
so they can be a better
value for the money.
Personally, in Italy, we're not
really used to having meals.
We are very accustomed to
just having a big main course.
That to me still feels a
bit of an American thing.
But this is American food,
so I guess we are using
their customs as well.
If you're operating under the assumption
that this is for seven people,
it's a pretty good deal.
But you and I both know
this ain't for seven people.
We want to see if there
are any similarities
in the nutrition of
KFC for both countries.
Now, this is our chicken sandwich,
and it has 650 calories.
And if you'll notice,
there's a lot of salt
and fat in this sandwich,
over half your daily recommended intake.
KFC Italy doesn't disclose their calories
on their website.
Actually, I think disclosing
nutritional information,
like calories and everything,
I find that quite an American thing.
That doesn't mean it's good or bad.
It's just like, we don't really
tend to count calories in things.
Every "Food Wars" we've
done, all the nutrition info,
all the ingredients info, in the US,
you can get it, no problem.
Other countries, they don't provide it.
Let's take a look at some ingredients
that KFC uses here in Italy.
Here are all the
ingredients for the fries.
Nine is a lot.
Potatoes and frying oil, how about two?
Two ingredients, and a bit
of salt, and one chemical.
Let's just use one, you
know, if we have to.
And here are all the ingredients
of the fries in the US.
33 ingredients.
That's 24 more than the
ingredients in Italy's fries.
That's nuts.
Claudia: Nine ingredients for this thing,
and it doesn't even hold its shape.
I would expect it to be perfect.
There's a lot of flavors
and colorings that we use,
like paprika, turmeric,
and annatto extract color,
which is funny we put that into the fries,
but when making this, KFC also
uses bleached white flour,
which removes all the color,
so it seems kind of counterproductive.
Like, they're taking all the color out
with the bleached flour, right?
And they're putting all
those chemicals back in
to make them look like fries.
I don't know why we do that either.
So, let's have a look at the ingredients
for a chicken drumstick.
Italy's chicken uses a
lot of flavor enhancers,
gums, and stabilizers.
For example, xanthan gum and guar gum.
They're used in meat products
to keep the chicken tender
during the cooking process.
These gums are also used for chicken
that has a batter around
it, so that when it's fried,
it absorbs less oil.
As I said before, Italians
don't really look at ingredients
or nutritional value of things.
And that is why I think there is
a lot of work done beforehand for us
in order to make the food
as simple as possible,
so that if you do look at the ingredients,
you are not so shocked by it.
And here are the ingredients
of the chicken in the US.
Surprisingly smaller than Italy's list,
although the US has not noted
what oil they use for frying,
like Italy has.
So it would probably add
a few more ingredients.
Now, KFC actually uses pressure frying
instead of deep frying,
like the other chains,
as it allows for faster cooking time
and always keeps the meat moister,
as less steam evaporates.
Let's take a closer look
at a few ingredients
that some of us may not recognize.
OK, first up, sodium phosphate.
Now, it helps stabilize the pH of the food
to keep them together.
But it's also popular
over-the-counter medicine
for bowel movements.
So don't be surprised if eating KFC
makes you rush to the bathroom.
Next up, monosodium glutamate,
flavor enhancer commonly added
to soups and processed meats.
Ugh. We're putting these
names on-screen, right?
Ah, this word looks like this
and is probably pronounced
dime-thigh-polo-sigh-lexane.
Computer: Dimethylpolysiloxane.
It's an antifoaming agent
derived from silicone,
usually added to oils,
jams, and canned vegetables.
Disodium dihydrogen pyrophosphate.
This should be a contest. Anyway. OK.
Prevents potatoes in the
fries from turning brown
due to oxidization,
which is natural for most
fruits and vegetables.
And just to add that all these ingredients
have been approved by health professionals
and there are no safety concerns,
as long as they're eaten
in lower quantities,
which, in general, is good
advice for eating fast food.
Chickens in the US are free of
added hormones and steroids.
However, KFC does not disclose much else
about how the chicken is prepared,
nor how much chicken is used per item.
As of 2019, Yum Brands,
the parent company of KFC,
stopped purchasing chicken
raised using antibiotics.
So I guess they're heading
in the right direction.
KFC opened their first outlet in the '70s
in Naples for some reason.
And then that didn't work
out, and they closed.
And then they came back to Italy in 2014.
The objective was to open
100 branches in four years.
They're not quite there yet.
As of 2022, the stats say
that they've opened 68
branches here in Italy.
Although it's been here since 2014,
it does still feel pretty new.
Like, Italians are not so big on chicken,
especially grilled chicken.
It does still feel like
a very foreign idea.
KFC is so popular in the US,
maybe the most popular chicken chain,
fried-chicken chain at least.
I think it's the
fried-chicken chain to beat in the US.
There's other chicken places
that do chicken sandwiches,
chicken burgers. But as
far as chicken on the bone,
I don't know who's even
competing with KFC.
Ah, I guess there's Popeyes.
Oh, yeah, Popeyes.
No, I think KFC is way
more popular than Popeyes.
I didn't say it's better.
If a KFC opens in a new town,
for example, in my hometown
they opened last year,
there are huge lines.
There are a lot of people
that want to try it
because it's really the idea
of the American fast-food
chain that's arriving.
So it's exciting. It's different.
Again, it's one of those
things that I think
you do try it because of the hype.
KFC adaptability is
weird. A couple years ago,
there used to be a lot
more stuff on the menu.
And now there's a lot less.
So their adaptability is
less about making stuff
that kind of caters to people's tastes,
and more like, "No
one's getting the wings,
let's just do the nuggets.
Let's take all this stuff off the menu,
let's pare it down, go,
go, go," for efficiency,
and probably because it's
cheaper to have less ingredients.
So they've adapted to, I don't know,
shifts in the market or
people's interest in KFC.
They really don't deviate
too far, dish-wise,
from, like, a fried chicken
or a chicken in a bun.
KFC is actually the chain that has made
the least effort to Italianize the menu.
I don't know. Actually, weirdly,
I think that for this it works,
because the idea of eating fried chicken
is so foreign to us that I
don't know how you would,
how would you make that Italian?
You'd maybe put some, like,
fried courgette flowers with the chicken?
I don't know.
For me to even think about
a similar Italian thing,
that, weirdly, I think this
may be working the way it is.
So we'll see when they
will reach 100 branches.
Maybe sooner than we think.
Make note of the fun Colonel
Sanders doing a cartwheel.
Wasn't this guy, like, 70
when he started Kentucky Fried Chicken?
There's no way.
If he's doing that, it's against his will.
Moments before the ambulance was called.